you want to have a good time tonight
[Music]
[Music]
going up
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
expensive
[Music]
is
[Music]
sense of danger
not one from a danger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
ring ring ring ring ring ring ring
hello and welcome to moses and friends
i'm your host moses storms
show where we take all of our favorite
people from the conan show we put them
up
in your living room uh we have a pack
show today so i want to get to my first
guest right away because i just got
my 2020 ballot sent to me
for local elections the big one the
president i know nothing about
politics so i want to bring on an expert
in politics
my friend your friend flulaborg lula
hello democracy
is good democracy lula can't legally
vote
in this country because of his uh german
situation
yeah we're calling it thank you yeah
keep it vague so this is great i have a
sticker for when i finish i feel good
about that
so let's go through this ballot um i'm
sure if you live in california you have
one that looks similar if you live in a
different state
maybe your deadlines pass this is your
official election guide
presented by flulaborg
so the first one on the ballot right
here is
uh nithya rahman vs david rue for
los angeles city general municipal
election
member of the city council fourth
district yes uh
what should i fill in well let me tell
you just a little story um so some
backstory ramen
nissa ramen she invented a soup
the ramen soup she's in charge of that
she feels like this has been an ancient
soup it's been around for a while she
seems like a younger woman but was
passed down from the generations
you know like um like like back spasms
so let's go with uh los angeles
community college district member of the
board trustees
seat one our options are tory bailey
uh charney tustin oh yeah yeah pause
um i will tell you right away always
select someone that has
a nice symbol above a letter in germany
we have umlauts i'm loving those dots
people
so if there are dots or perhaps a little
snippy snappy above
this is who you pick okay so until day
alone
yeah we're gonna go well any day it's
gonna
if you're voting whatever this is this
is thursday sunday till day any day
that's who you select okay this feels
like a crime at this point this bit
feels like we're going into a crime
judge of the superior court this seems
really important
uh office number 80. our options are
david a burger or clint james
you know you know just like with mcguire
jerry you had me at
burger it's a delicious thing anything
that sounds like tasty calories
they win my friend johannes sauerkraut
one time ran
for a small a district of education seat
in germany he lost
why nobody eats it okay
[Music]
this one i feel like i've been hearing a
lot in the news a lot of protests i went
to some of these district attorney uh
jackie lacy versus george uh gascon
i can tell you why there is an issue um
lacie is running for the first time
without
her partner cagney and so is a problem
if it was cagney and lacy everyone would
be like yay great wonderful times but
because cagney is now i don't understand
what cagney is doing i think running a
fish store
or something so this is the issue it's
because acne is not available so she's
running like 50 percent power
essentially yeah it doesn't have lacing
cagney
and lacie it's cagney and lacy moses
okay yeah yeah that seems like an
outdated reference for a comedy duo that
i
i do not know oh google it wow one of
the hottest comebacks of 2009
was google visit
[Music]
state measure 17. we're getting under
measures we're getting onto problems
twice vote once restores the right to
vote after completion of a prison term
this is an issue
yeah yeah you went to prison you paid
your dose let them vote [ __ ]
measure 19 changes to certain property
tax
rules oh i like that so vague property
owner yes i just recently purchased
three night clubs very cheap
during the pandemic uh so oh this is
about this yes
um i would like to raise all of these
taxes no one is attending my night clubs
currently i'm djing hardcore no one is
here i would like to punish people uh
for not coming to my nightclub so yes
you purchased three nightclubs during a
global pandemic lockdown yes i purchased
the one behind the gelsons you know
heartsy totsies
uh uh yeah where do you think i got my
lip ring hello
and also abcdefps also i purchased
uh just uh down the stairs you know down
the street from the pf chance on the
promenade and then
i purchased just a whole basement it's a
garden apartment
it was a techno studio and now it's mine
so yes you want to tax anyone that comes
to your club and doesn't come
[Music]
now we have a big one coming up i think
i think i'm gonna need some help with
this
i need some help with my life at this
point so i'm gonna bring on my next
guest if you stick around for a second
you know where from sona fixes your life
and i think she can fix a lot right now
please welcome trusty assistant
sono mo session sona do we have you
she is in a pitch black room now ah
there you lost power sonar
from sauna fixes your life so now we're
going through this ballot and um
i need your help and flula's help we
have the big one coming up okay this is
the official california ballot
um these are our presidential options we
of course have
biden and harris trump and pence
we have uh rook rocky and i guess vice
president
kanye oh which i didn't did you know he
was stepped down to vice president i
didn't know that i thought he was still
president
right well according to this ballot it's
he's he's running as the vice president
so i think even he's trying to distance
himself maybe
he realized he's not qualified enough
for president and he's like i am
qualified enough for
vice president i think that was a smart
choice so quote
rocky is more qualified his name is
rocky
is that a human yeah is rocky a human or
is it like a coloring book
what is it literally never heard outside
of the bit
never heard of this human being would
you vote for
rocky because like keep in mind the vice
president's not really going to do a lot
um do you think do you think rocky is
trustee sonar
you know what i haven't seen my ballot
yet don't they have little descriptions
underneath
each candidate or am i making that up it
just says for president i mean under the
the local ones it says like yeah yeah
liberal progressive educator
entrepreneur under president is just
like
this guy's 35 and he'll do it
okay the bar could not be lower the
presidential one yeah
yeah you know what this is the
presidential race is there more is that
it uh well then there's howie
hawkins which sounds made up it sounds
like the name you give out when you're
lying at a restaurant
um honey hopkins with angela nicole
walker
and then joe jorgensen and also some
fake
and then jeremy spike cohen
wow i knew a guy on my birthright trip
jeremy cohen i think he's trying to go
by spike
now yeah this is a really tough one
i don't know about you guys but i think
that this might be the
most difficult president to choose
ever ever yeah it's never been clear
like
this has never been more vague who to
select what do you think i would suggest
yeah yeah if you can write somebody in i
would suggest you michael dukakis
yeah he got a raw steal in 1988 was up
very very high and then what happened i
don't know and then boom poof disappears
right the tank and he's gone
michael duke is sorry familiar with
michael dukakis
i think it's a little before our time
we're in our 50s yeah michael duca i
mean
i've heard of him well everything is
taped in lay in germany so i'd heard
about
michael dukakis in 2018 was kind of a
new
he like had a nice little whoa he's
famous watch out watch out
it's michael duke it's usually not good
when someone's famous and they say
watch out watch out that historically
has not been great
hey michael the goggles watch out
it has you're right now that i realized
a german man with an accent screaming
this bad idea
watch out watch out it's not just like
watch out it's
too dude like he's like his car's
backing into you
as he sexually harasses you all right so
i'm gonna write down michael dukakis i
guess i don't know i
i personally like to choose the
candidate with the best
teeth i'm a big and just for oral
hygiene
and literally nothing else there's no
what the reason
i would ever choose him over anybody
else it's gotta be biden
yeah biden's teeth looks like it when
you have your printer and it runs out of
black ink and just like
the white comes out that's like 60 of
his face it's just those
those big old gams
so we finished the ballot sony you've
yet to receive your ballot do you know
what to do with your ballot
i think flula knows well step one uh
find a very no a local uh
creek or riverbed throw this into the
riverbed
so we'll throw these in a river when we
get them and then they flow down
to your local election hall yeah and
then everyone at the election
they scoop the river like it's like
they're panning for gold
except they're panning for ballots so
just hope they find your ballot
uh as they go streaming down directly
into baja
actually someone's knocking on the door
it sounds
like um ice let me let me see it's
maybe it's oh no
no don't get it don't don't answer you
don't have to answer
if anyone's watching you don't have to
answer for i okay he's gone
i think guys i told them no german would
own a trombone
yes they're all nice tricks oh i got it
hey good luck guys try next door yeah
wait so did you answer you answered the
door with the trombone and they were
like
wrong address i opened the door always
and i just go
and as soon as you do this everyone's
like oops harmless
homeless stay so heartless stay
i mean you have tips for people yeah you
should not try that if ice delivers the
door don't go to the door with the
trombone you know what fools i
wrote down the parts the beginning that
made me laugh the ramen family
how it was her family invented ramen
that killed me
and you opened three nightclubs
not one not two three three yeah yes
all good things come in threes and also
all tragedies you don't know until you
try
so this is true wow sound this
advice that sounds yeah it sounds like a
truth yeah
based on no information yeah three night
clubs i mean we have a place to go we at
least have a shelter
yes oh yeah you guys can sleep and i
will play some nice tasty reggaeton
oh my god the quarantines really hit you
hard when you started playing reggaeton
moses you don't know what you missing
lula borg everyone with your official
guide to the 2020 california ballot
thank you so much who gave us a lot to
go on so welcome moses bye bye sona you
are great
bye flools that was fun this was fun
yeah it's fun that uh we're all
definitely on a watch list now for sure
i might need a new ballot i think i'm
just gonna vote in person
i'm just gonna do it you're gonna brave
it yeah i think i'm just too nervous
but i mean i don't have any reason to be
you could just drop it off at a polling
place and you could track it but i'm
just like too scared
what about after the election are you
worried at all of like
whatever the results are some people are
gonna be a little
unhappy is there any part of you it's
like maybe i'll get out of a major city
i'll get out of los angeles
i didn't think about that until right
now so thanks for putting that idea
into my head um oh good i like to put as
many
thoughts i see a window behind you and
it's a sliding one so sliding
windows as long as they don't go down
are always openable from the outside
oh hey that's a fun thing to know thank
you for that
that's a really cool thing to know in my
new house
in this new neighborhood uh that there
is a point of entry
for people if they just want to come
inside you should be very worried
cells proliferate and then it creates
disease wait are you doing a bit is that
real
is it real that you can no it's like oh
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
no no no no you you're you're fine
you're safe
okay is this the new house yeah because
on the show you had made the entire
studio audience on conan yell
um buy me a house
i don't think there's anything people
like more
than someone asking someone who's very
wealthy
to buy them something very expensive and
i think the way the entire audience just
turned on conan
and then just started chanting with me
it's one of the most thrilling moments
of my life i think when you're on tv
people have this idea that you have
millions of dollars if you've ever
appeared on on television before
you are a billionaire and could just
afford a house because people were like
well you could pay for that and i'm like
i made 47
the inflated sense that we have that
anyone on tv is
cash rich though it's fair that conan
could afford to buy you a house in deep
glendale uh well
first of all it's al tadina and i think
you saw glendale
cause i'm armenian yes which
congratulations
on the it's not what you say when you
raise awareness
what uh the is that what that is
because i i've i will be fine to admit
that i was ignorant to it i thought it
was like a reminder of hey this terrible
genocide happened
but there's a new issue there's an area
in uh
there's an area near azerbaijan in
armenia called artsakh and then the
soviet union gave it to azerbaijan but
it's like 95
armenian and they govern it and they
run it and then azerbaijan just suddenly
brought turkey in
and was like hey turkey come and let's
let's invade this area
and armenians are like what the [ __ ]
and so yeah that's what's happening
right now it's awful
i mean it could become an all-out war
and you know armenians in la were very
vocal very vocal shut down the 101. yeah
so you've probably seen a lot of
armenian flags on a lot of cars there's
a bunch of
a bunch of cars on on the 101 and they
saw the the orange and blue flag
everywhere unless i just passed two
weeks i've been
really getting it out there but i've
just been not paying attention to the
message but now we know now you know
you've been doing a team cocoa show sono
mustafi and fixes your life
where you've talked about hey how you
could scam the uh
pet support system as my pet animal
how do i convince my husband then our
landlord we need a pet
you need a pet look up all the reasons
people have
service dogs whether it's like social
anxiety then it becomes like a medical
issue
you've also talked about uh something
called juice juice says how do you
manage a stressful day at work
something called juice juice time
trouble at work you're stressed
um drink on the job that's juice juice
time
you know am i qualified some would say
maybe i'm not
but i think that i am because i've lived
and so
when these people ask me these questions
that are very serious
i like to re like take from my
experiences
and say when i'm stressed at work i do
things like i
have juice juice time which is you take
a normal looking beverage whatever it is
orange juice
and you put a little bit of vodka in
there
or any other type of alcohol that's
easily accessible
and you put it on your desk in a uh
in a like water bottle or some sort of
hidden vessel
it's a cocktail yes you mix alcohol with
you're telling a non-alcoholic beverage
right you take something i don't know
we'll call it like you mix it so let's
call it a mixer
it's kind of mixing you take some
alcohol
and you put it in this mixer and then
yeah uh you know that way you can have a
nice
buzz but you're not getting like you
know
hollywood boulevard wasted at work okay
so it flies under the radar i'm always
nervous about that even for like
doing stand-up online like that people
would know i'm drunk for something has
anyone caught on to you
in the office been to your desk it's
fluorescent
lights there's always an episode of
friends playing
shotgun there's anyone been like hey you
seem happy
what's wrong yeah uh it's happening
first of all i should say i don't do
juice time all the time i think that's
like
that's a problem yeah but i don't know
but when i do
do it my eyes do kind of glaze over
and uh my reaction time slows down
and so i think people are like
do you have a do you have a fun lunch
that's code for that i don't know
what sounds different about you like i
got highlights and they're like what
yeah and then they're after the next
thing yeah sona fixes your life i think
that i've
fixed a lot of lives it's amazing what
you can do by just answering
a single question that people have could
you fix my life right now
i'm supposed to go back out on the road
because um i'm supposed to shoot this
special
and some comedy clubs are open i know
hbo max special some comedy clubs are
open
and i'm a little worried right now i
think if i fix my life that maybe the
clubs aren't the most sanitary
environments that maybe they're not
taking as seriously as
like a big brand like target because
just like a comedy club employee
it's like yeah what that down no comedy
clubs are
have always been disgusting yeah i'm
gonna digress for a second
so uh i feel like i've never seen like
an
updated comedy club and so
you have no like okay so once i went
this is really random i went to the
playboy mansion once yeah
and i went there not for a party i went
there for a nice
lunch with two other people and we just
sat
and we had lunch there was no like naked
girls running around or anything
but then i got a tour of the playboy
mansion after and they took us to this
one room
open this door and the floor is like a
soft cushy bed
and it's clear that there were just like
orgies on orgies on orgies in here
and i don't think that they changed
that flooring since like 1976
right because there's no fitted sheet
for a floor
well it's like it's like the carpet it's
just it's weird it was like a
very soft flooring my point is i look at
comedy clubs that same way as i do as
that room that was in
the playboy mansion yeah and like back
in the day people were like
doing it and they were like doing coke
and whatever
so there's like the entire club is just
full of
jizz and coke remnants
and like drinks yeah that people spilled
and people laughing and they're spit all
over the place
and the jizz if you're a good comedian
the whole audience is
[ __ ] so much just everything you see
the comics choosing yeah you are right
that they're not updated at all
in the fact that there'll still be like
photos up of of cancelled comedians that
were canceled a long time ago like that
guy was canceled for doing jokes about
the challenger
and that's a lot but i think you'll be
fine
okay here's the thing so your advice for
me is i think you'll be fine
and watch out for jizz puddles yeah
like you've been to protests i've been
to protests
yeah that like i thought that they were
gonna be really scary if you have a mask
and you stay away from people and you
don't touch
any of anything in the comedy club then
i think you're gonna be fine
okay yeah if you're gonna catch anything
it's gonna be like
syphilis not cold right it's going to be
a hepatitis is going to be
yeah one of the strange which we have
vaccines for it's fine
please i always say don't let hepatitis
dominate your life yeah
give me hepatitis no that was terrible
no doubt no i was trying to say like
oh i'd rather have something that's
treatable than
what you're just included in the
diy conan where they reanimated
fans of the show reanimated your
interview when you're on the show after
kumau cancelled yeah so there's
animators submitting there's people
playing you
how how did you feel about the betrayal
i loved it for the most part
for the most part it was all very
flattering and sweet
there was one that someone drew
where i looked like 400 pounds
is this the one that you had superpowers
like you come out and you
i completely evaporate andy
that's not it but now you're making me
think that there's an oh maybe that is
it was a it was a hand-drawn animation
where i'm like
your signature face your head shot yeah
oh my god this person has
no neck you know when they put a tin
mark like right here
and then it's just like yeah the space
oof oh is that how people see me but i
you know it's fine but everything else
it was really sweet i
i i mean you know i can't see it the
drawings are tough
and i think what happens when people
draw you is they accentuate the
one feature about your face that you
maybe don't like it's the most extreme
in an effort to capture you yeah and
it's flattery but
it is the meanest roast of your life
you're like oh
well now i'm worried about that part
what's the feature let's talk
about it the photo of me looked like it
looked like uh if
dobby from harry potter was allowed to
become a real boy
[Music]
it is very troubling
was just like oh we gave him some man
features like every time they do those
things of like
like homer simpson what if he looked
like what would he look like as a real
human he looked like that but with dobby
oh but moses i think that just means
that you're very like
delic you're delicate but i die on a
beach
yeah yeah like not i'm not trying to be
mean but you
are you look like a prince from another
era that like no one was allowed to
touch
a delicate prince yes
that that is what i go what's my brand a
delicate prince and don't touch
me sir this
that's somehow worse than the animation
that's worse than the drawing come on
it's nice you know what's good about it
is if somebody comes up to you and is
like trying to underestimate you
like i mean ken i'm a delicate prince
you're not allowed to touch me i'm a
prince not even a king a prince means i
didn't even earn it i was born into the
status
don't touch my crimson milk skin have
you ever been in a fight
i feel like you're just like a lover not
a fighter yeah i was in a
fight uh maybe i was like 19. have you
been in a fight
never i've been in a lot of verbal
fights but never a physical one
it is insane when you zoom out of a
because like my girlfriend and i are
very close and we're also very loud
together
it started like we were making fun of
couples that had like weird names which
are like sugar kiki i'm like what's
the worst nickname but now we've
completely abandoned that bit so we're
actually calling each other like you're
garbage you're pee
and there was just a woman like watering
her plants that
had never hurt us before so terrifying
oh my god i love your girlfriend
can you tell what kind you guys say she
loves you
she's always mad in the corner over
there you just keep her in the corner
while you do this
just tell her like don't move from that
spot got the i keeper there she takes up
residence in the corner
we'll mark her territory with some pee
and then
she's always ready to attack so for the
viewers at home just know that my
girlfriend's ready to attack
she's up on the feeling like the movie
hereditary where she's uh
like ready to pounce she wants me to
stop doing the show
she's she creates all these burner
accounts so all the youtube comments
like do you show socks where's conan
it's all her oh my god that's the
twinkle of fear is in my eyes so how do
i fix that
fix my life um i think you just give her
whatever she wants
soda thank you so much for joining us
that was fun i
love talking to you moses right let's do
this when it's not recorded i'm down
where are you where are you okay are you
in
uh let me give you my exact address on
the air yeah
this this and
really just yeah yeah yeah but we're the
only people still here in in l.a
yeah well world's ending thank you so
much for joining us
sonam assassins your life is the show go
to the team
coco instagram you could see it all bye
bye sauna
say hi to contour for me
come too she won't come off the ceiling
okay classic
all right bye all right the centum
obsession my next guest you know from
his
multiple comedy specials on comedy
central uh he's got a new album
out that is uh animated thing i want to
talk to him about please welcome my
friend kyle kanan kyle do we have you
what's up buddy thank you for being here
uh
well not here anymore we used to be
neighbors and then you just moved
to uh portland yeah you saw me posted up
in front of the u-haul
the other day yeah i i they don't like
californians up here so i brought i
brought a lot of flannel i brought an
axe just to just get in with like
my face yeah i was gonna wear it and
then i was wearing it for like
a half hour and i lost enthusiasm for
the bit it is weird
i i what are you telling people because
neighbors are asked like what do you do
and it's weird to be like i'm a comedian
i moved from the entertainment capital
to here i don't ever tell anybody i'm a
comedian what do you think
i never want people to know that because
then then the expectations on i just
want to be like hey that guy's pretty
fun
and then because if they people know
you're a comedian and you're not fun
they're like this guy sucks
that guy with the super pac is really
fun yeah i'm just kind of the guy
like i'm just watering the lawn up here
they nobody knows anything about me i've
met the neighbors the the mailman's
already seen me nude once that was a
mishap
how's that happen well i'm not used to
living on the ground floor you know
you live in an apartment you're on the
second floor and this is nudity
all the time on the second floor because
nobody's looking nobody's cares
that's too much that vantage point here
i'm on the first floor
for getting and living my life regular
and i thought i was the laundry's in the
garage
and there's windows on a garage door i
haven't seen that ever that's not city
life
windows on a garage door get out of here
right well that's portland where
everyone like
has a roommate that lives in the garage
yeah
i was taking off all my clothes to put
them in the wash in the garage you know
you're doing your laundry and then you
get to that point like well i
what if all my clothes are clean at once
oh yeah i've been tempted to do that but
the
the uh it's on the third floor so i have
to like walk down
shirtless i don't be that guy in the
building but that is a good thought
now i'm in a house and i can finally
achieve
that every single piece of clothing
clean at the same time feeling
i i disrobe yeah dunk the clothes i
i figured i got three seconds window
just to dunk the clothes get back in the
house
that's the same amount of time that the
mailman is walking up the driveway
and i just he just i looked at him and
he
where he was wearing like some oakley
blades so i'm sure his eyes
saw it but i couldn't judge it he kept a
a straight enough look but um
that was like the first week we were
here so i don't know you got walked in
by the cool mailman who got into his
lifted mail truck
rolling coal out of the van did it take
a lot for you to move i mean first off
we
didn't hire movers and i don't know why
i could i could have afforded that i
just like we'll do it ourselves
you know wow stupidest thing i've ever
done in my life you pack
you pack so much stuff that you think
you're gonna need and then after you
transport it
uh thousands of miles and you're like oh
i never
i never needed this i didn't i didn't
need a i didn't need this vhs
uh collection of happy days i have
no less than 200 different half full
hotel moisturizers
the cheapest moisturizer it's always
lemon scented do you want to smell like
lemon
smell like lemon and just be slick for a
good part of your day
i have so many of those i think it's
just white motor oil there's no way it
never absorbs
your skin your skin's like i don't want
that all the antibodies in your body
are like this shouldn't be in me this
why does this keep staining my shirts
this can't be good for my skin
i was just aiming away at fabric if
someone just has a lighter in the room i
instantly
bursted the flames you smother cotton
balls with those for you to start
campfires when you're going camping it's
good
yeah i have uh three different lip balms
just on my desk
all packed these unnecessary
i got i'm i'm ready i got like i said
this is the first time yeah did you get
a gun because it's the first time i've
thought like i totally have against gun
control absolutely there should be a
check but this is the first time where
it feels like
a good purchase it feels like yeah yeah
i bought a gun you know i bought a gun
because you ever look at the people in
line at the gun store
they're getting guns that's why i got a
gun yeah
this muffin top creep and a punisher
t-shirt's going to be armed
i'll lose i'm going to lose the civil
war but at least i want to lose with
some effort you know
it would make me feel more comfortable
if the guys buying guns were a little
more in shape
because they would at least try to do
the fist fight before
but this the line is like well that
guy's gonna go immediately for the gun
so he doesn't have to do stairs
yeah you're just indiana jones with the
guy with the scimitar
in the marketplace like he's gonna want
you to shoot this guy like
well come on man how about a little fair
fight it starts with a roast battle
i mean that's what we can bring to the
table it should be a roast batter you
should be able to take it and it should
be some sort of physical agility test
that you should take to be like you
could
try to throw one punch at least before
you go to the gun
throwing stars that's a that's nice but
you are right and that is the it's the
people that are buying guns
it's like well then we want one we're
not gonna be like i have a sign
i'm gonna shame you online like that
doesn't win
there are gonna be like so like in the
next 18
months i'm sure there's going to be so
many like different
i don't know like improvisers and tv
writers with accidental bullet wounds
yeah that's good i wrote on caroline in
the city and now i have a small militia
operating out of burbank oh my god that
that went right through my air force one
i can't believe it
right through my new new balances it's a
weird time now you think you'd think it
would be easy to choose a side because
one of the sides has
nazis remember those those are back you
think you'd be like well even if they
got other stuff that's like meat
the nazi thing kind of cancels like wow
but free ice cream every other tuesday
hold on i love ice cream wait a minute
so you guys have nazis
oh man even if they check
every box nazis is still on there like i
gotta go to the other guy it's it's the
cartoon version it's the first question
on who wants to be a millionaire like
that's the obvious
joke answer is not the one with nazis i
already look like i'm in some sort of
bunker like i'm just peering out the
blinds
yeah they're coming man it's the mailman
there's no way he shouldn't have shown
up that time he's in on it
well that's what's funny about the
mailman is that he came back the next
day
and i was out watering the lawn and i
had like a joke
70s outfit from a party but i had very
limited clothing up here when we were
living here over the summer
so i was just saying cut off jean shorts
and like a
red mesh tank top and i just look like
phillip seymour hoffman's character from
boogie nights and i'm out there watering
the lawn
and he comes rolling up and like all
right now i look like i'm just trying to
court this fella
right like the housewife that's like oh
whoops you caught me
um hey there postman nice kitties
uh what was the idea behind portland
because of all the cities i mean a lot
of people make the move to
austin not many people are going from la
which is not doing great right now to
portland which is
at least media wise not going great oh
i mean we're in the burbs so and i like
the burbs i grew up in the burbs and
when you grow up in the burbs you feel
like you're trapped and like nothing
good ever came out of there
but then i left and i lived my life and
now i'm back in the burbs i'm like i dig
this place
people respect the four-way stop sign
there's good grocery stores i got a
grocery store with a solid hot bar
how do you feel about the hot bar moses
i feel great until they start
like we have orange chicken like i don't
think vons knows what they're doing with
orange chicken
i really i would think anybody can do
orange chicken i would
i would question them when they're like
i would question vaughn's i'm like this
is goat cheese like you just found that
cheese
yeah that's just goat cheese it's just
bad mozzarella but never once have i
eaten orange chicken and ever gotten a
hint of what i thought was
chicken in it oh yeah right because it's
all
yeah it's all the batter it's just candy
it's it's like movie candy made out of
poultry
and i'm not that's not a complaint
that's not exactly right
do you think it's gonna change your
point of view at all because a lot of
stand-up i mean you're always on the
edge
you're not living in great circumstances
your life is always on the road do you
think it's and then now you're in the
suburbs
i don't know i just maybe i need to let
that go but there is a thing like if i'm
too comfortable i can't do this
outdated medium that doesn't exist
anymore
what's the angle man oh there's just
some bum in the burbs now all right what
are you gonna talk about a podcast kyle
yeah but what do i what am i gonna do be
the 50 year old who's still just
amped up and like oh man let me tell you
in the gristle hustle
bustle like i can talk about a fire pit
that i got in the yard if i can't make a
joke about the fire pit and the stray
cat that i hang out with
then then i'm not a good comic if you're
a good comic you can you can talk about
whatever situation
i love grocery stores i've written jokes
about grocery stores i'll continue to be
your number one grocery store humorist
on stage hey you ever see a tv dinner
just abandoned in the beer aisle
that's me can i go back to be
i am impressed at how long it took sona
to describe just what a cocktail was
just like when you take alcohol yeah
think but then you put it in a thing
that's not alcohol
like you like like it's two different
drinks but one's alcohol
but then you mix them together and then
that's like a different drink i'm like
that's the
do you think i waited the appropriate
time to slam dunk because i was like
maybe this is going somewhere maybe this
is a twist besides
orange juice sona wait till you meet a
bartender they are going to see
let's just pop that to you i will recall
that let's just call that mix a
screwdriver i don't know
how'd you come up with that name i
pulled it out of my ass i don't know
yeah it took everything in me to not be
like uh
actually thank you for coming on the
show but that exists
i i i adored the innocence of it
you're gonna have some interesting
stories to follow yeah so
this year you put out an animated album
uh trampoline
in a ditch where if i'm not wrong
essentially
visual artists were able to take your
jokes or at least a segment of your
album
and do whatever they wanted with it
without you really meddling in it
yeah i kind of yeah it just turned out
great and i just told them to run with
it because like that's they're
i'm not going to direct them on how to
animate something they're the animators
go crazy with it and it turned out
better than i could expect do you have
anything like
what sona and i were talking about where
sometimes if people animate you're like
okay well gut actually doesn't look like
that but was there any notes like that
or you
just couldn't no because i mean well
they were like it wasn't user submitted
they were professional artists so i kind
of was
you know relied on the professionalism
but
just doing stuff online with an active
colleague doing zoom shows with active
commentary it's the same kind of thing
we're like oh i'm trying to do jokes and
then people get to comment
on the screen while you're telling your
jokes
and they'll just say something like does
he have a big head or just really tiny
arms and then
you just lay awake at night thinking
like wow both
i don't know yeah i haven't even thought
that far but okay
that was what i got when you're talking
about people commenting or
drawing you in a certain way people will
heckle through the
comment section and you can't do
anything about it there's no get this
guy out of here it's like nope
it's just a one sentence that's gonna
live with me till the end of days
i'll read that and think about that
actually can't kick him out actually him
commenting whatever main thing actually
helps us yeah i guess now i have to do
pull-ups
yeah yeah it is a weird thing where it
is shifting where it feels really
outdated even next week the date i'm
doing
like we kind of move past this like just
a guy talking yeah something
give him a give him a cartoon give the
folks a cartoon
so i'll give him a little cartoon to
watch you didn't just see me meander
around the stage
another guy that looks like this telling
you how he thinks the world works oh
good
but it's different because he's got a
red curtain behind him with some purple
light
and some smoke the smoke is nice it just
makes everyone look better you know and
it's a great
foresight into the future we'll all be
performing in smoke you put effort into
your backdrop
i should have i'm moving so that's my
excuse you talked me in six months and
it still looks at you
like this you'll know that i'm uh
depressed do you have big plans for this
room is it
this is the zoom room this is kyle tv
it's kyle tv is going down in here
i think start with the smoke machine
worry about the lights later but just
get as much
smoke in that room it just looks like a
hazard that's all it looks like
all right well i can i can do about five
minutes tonight but i can't do ten
otherwise this guy okay every zoom show
every every appearance and we want you
to you know plug plug manscape it's just
covered in your
these house fires are uh i mean they
said we had to evacuate them like i got
the spot on hot tub tonight first so
after that then we'll get to find the
cat and get load up the car
i'll think a little higher from the
smoke just because it's so oxygen
i'm breaking just firemen coming in
hold on i didn't get to my closer
someone think about how handshakes are i
remember guys if nobody's gonna be
[Laughter]
well i hope to see important i mean if
i'm still alive and you're still alive
you should come out to the show hell
yeah man i'll do a little feature set
i'd love to get buried by someone that
features i'll take this axe and hack my
way through
southeast portland to get to the club
yeah
yeah this is great this is a lot of fun
i think uh you should come back is
exactly one to have you on
but next time with more smoke more smoke
and
me remembering that it was happening
right so i don't get high in the garage
first
get high what if everything i own was
washed at once
like parts in the dryer that's how it
happened and then i was gonna take a
shower and every facet of my life would
be clean
it all solves it all right kyle kennedy
thank you so much animated
album like the sections of it it's
called um it's it's
trampoline in a ditch right there's a
full album and then there's some
animated stuff around there
thanks kyle it was great talking to you
man thanks buddy kyle kanan everyone
huge thank you to sonoma obsession and
flu labor
for teaching us how to vote i gotta get
down to the river we'll be back soon i'm
moses storm good night
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
three
she made a piece
three
[Music]
is
[Music]
but it's hard to say
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that is
[Music]
the kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign you